but when you are on the floor having
shoved a towel in your mouth to try and
cover the sound of you screaming so your
baby daughter doesn't hear because you
don't want her to be afraid in sort of
two rooms away while your wife looks
after her i think it's impossible for
anyone no matter what their relationship
to masculinity to feel diminished by
that
what is your expertise what gives you
license to write a book about anxiety
so
the awful truth is
is that i was sitting down having
written sort of a couple of novels and
thinking what can i write about and i'd
written non-fiction before i was like
what am i an expert
because like you say like when you're
pitching something whether it's like an
article or a book
one of one of the four pitch lines units
like this is a story about this or i
wanted to look into this the reason why
i'm the person to do this and you
shouldn't get a better known celebrity
to do it instead is because this is my
area of expertise and i was like what am
i an expert on and
it was like well
i'm mentally ill like i guess like i'm
really anxious like i was like at the
time like i had a two-year-old daughter
um she's still she's just older now i
still have a daughter she's just older
but um
and i i was really struggling with like
severe anxiety and
panicked that was like i was having
panic attacks every week
sometimes i was having multiple ones a
day that would like put me on the floor
and i'd have several a day over like a
three-day period
and i was like this is
taking
this is just like this is unlivable
and also you know in my work i do doing
like a creative writing podcast i'd
started to have like neuroscientists on
i'd started having psychologists on i
studied like
four years of psychology back in school
but i'm not like qualified my background
is in in writing but i i'd spoken to
these
guys and had some really interesting
beginning talks about the brain
and you know the difference is when they
put like writers in an mri fmri scanner
and stuff like that and so i was like
think and then we signed my daughter up
to a developmental study where they
started studying her brain and the
development of kids at different ages
and
i got to take her in
and see they put this thing called an f
nears on her which is it's like a
portable scanner in a kind of skull cap
it looks like a medusa fright wig they
stick it on her head she looked like
uh like uh
well she looked like a crossfit medusa
and this is like a very
deep car
nerd reference but like uh when patrick
stewart plays like lucutius out of the
borg she looked like one of the borgs
she had like one art red eye piece on
that um tracks her vision and i was
seeing on a computer different parts of
her brain
lighting up uh
because of something called the bold
response the blood oxygen level
dependent response showing different
parts of a brain
uh as different levels of demand wanted
more or less oxygen and i was like i'm
watching my daughter think
we are at a level now where
psychology and neuroscience
we can like look inside people's heads
and i'm like there's got to like i only
get access to this because we've signed
up to this study but i'm like there's
got i now know i there's researchers out
there are willing to speak to me
uh for some reason
and
i guess the reason the thing was i just
wanted to get well and i was like well
if i say i'm writing a book
these people are going to open their
doors to me
exactly i'm going gonna be able to
grandfather myself in to speak to all
these people and then i'm gonna go like
and at the same time i'd like
or
you know like if you've got hay fever
everyone in your family will like send
you emails going hey i just read this
article with this like their homespun
remedy on how to beat hay fever and and
manuka honey yeah you need to spread the
manuka honey over your nasal nasal
cavity or something yeah exactly and you
you'll never be short of suggestions
well obviously people knowing that i was
really scared i i was never
short of people making suggestions
sending me articles and you see all
these articles saying this new treatment
has been found
so i was like
i keep reading that we're like five
years away from this treatments that's
going to blow it open whether it's a new
drug uh a new
uh sort of
a new strategy that people were doing
you know like i think you're social
prescribing people going for walks
forest bathing dice bars things like
that and i was like
what if i just go and speak to the
people there are people who are spending
their lives studying this
in all different disciplines what if i
go and speak to them and then i try
and do everything because the other
thing was i'd also read all the studies
on the effect of mental illness
a parent's mental illness on children
and how that stuff starts early and it
gets passed down and how across a whole
range of profiles it makes kids outcomes
worse and like stuff you'd expect like
their chance of mental illness being
worse but also crazy stuff like their
chance of having asthma and i was like
it
this i want my daughter to have the best
chance in life she can and like some of
us can be like really down on ourselves
and go like i can't do this
i'm not worth it but like
the the bottom line was do i think it's
worth having a go at this
for my daughter's sake you know if i
don't care about myself do i care about
her and the answer was like yeah that's
one hell of a motivator yeah
i know yeah and so that's that's how i
so
the you know the short answer to your
question was when i started out doing
this in terms of my
qualification i was quite smug i was
like i've been
i've been i've been really anxious for
ages i have the worst panic attacks out
of anyone i've ever encountered
i've read a lot of articles my nan has
sent me a lot of clippings i was like
i'll go and speak to a couple of
i'll speak to a couple of scientists
right and they'll kind of sprinkle like
a little bit of legitimacy pixie dust on
the top of it
they'll just quote stuff that i kind of
already know i'll go yeah yeah i thought
i'd sit in there i'd get into their labs
i'd chat with them and they'd tell me
stuff and i'd go because of course it's
this isn't it i'd go it's the amygdala
right and they go oh you know about that
oh you're a colleague and we'd kind of
like nod and they'd see that i was an
expert
and then and then i and then i'd go and
write my book and it's only when i went
out and started speaking to people and
they're going nut him it doesn't work
like that at all and i was like oh i'm
in deep trouble
i'm in really deep trouble
and then i just went down this rabbit
hole
read over a thousand peer-reviewed
studies
end-to-end
um
spoke to dozens of people including like
every
expert that i could find in all sorts of
disciplines
and by the end of it like at least what
i can say is i know
how little i know if that makes sense
like i know
how dumb i am now i know what the edges
of my um
knowledge in any given discipline are
well the difference is that you've got
that in the trenches experience you know
like even if it even if it wasn't uh
medical understanding originally you
were able to appreciate it from an ex
from an experiential standpoint right so
what
for the people that haven't had one how
do you describe what a panic attack
feels like
so i went to the
you i mean you can get a technical
answer right which is you go to the
dsm-5 and there's a list of symptoms
right and you have to have like x number
from a list of symptoms
and
uh
then then it's officially diagnosed a
psychiatrist could say yeah you've had a
panic attack right and i think
it's uh
just just like a hair under 8 000
possible like
acceptable combinations of symptoms you
can have for a panic attack so they're
incredibly diverse
but reading
the
explanation of what a panic attack is
it's kind of like licking a photograph
of an ice cream right like describing a
panic attack i could i can tell you that
it it it's
it feels like it can feel like you're
going mad
like you a lot of people especially men
don't know they've got panic disorder
until they present at a e
saying they're having a heart attack
they think that they're having a heart
attack that they're having cardiac
arrest
they go to a e
and the doctor's like no you're you're
having a panic attack because so many of
the symptoms are the same breathlessness
what they call like air hunger um but
also a feeling of like de-realization
which is really difficult to describe
until you've been through it but you can
feel like nothing's quite real like this
sudden feeling that you're in a dream
which is also why a lot of people who
are having a panic attack think they're
going mad or insane
um
your
your airways closing up
um
dizziness
uh racing heart sweating uh
trembling um you might start getting
pins and needles in your extremities
your extremities might start
um they call that pins and needles and
your them your
extremities might your fingers might
start going into claws which they call
tetany um which is to do with like
calcium deficiency as you breathe so
hard
um you might
obviously like feelings of dread and
fear
often
terror i mean my panic attacks but all
of this is like if i described like
you know they call it you know they'll
call it in the literature they'll say a
panic attack is like this feeling of
sudden dread and fear accompanied by
extreme physiological symptoms which is
a bit like calling like being kicked in
the balls like a sudden extreme pressure
to the testicles right like it's a very
very different thing to go through it um
and you're like hey hang on and even
after i've had one i'd look back and go
yeah but that's not so bad and then
you're going through it and you
you feel like you're dying
and it's ridic in a sense it is
ridiculous because you're not
but
there's various ways and various
elements that i would later learn
speaking to like pulmonary biologists
and uh psychiatrists uh about the
physiology that makes it actually very
difficult to think straight while you're
having one it's not just a failure of
character um
so that's what it is but i would say
like they can present very differently
some people have talked to me having we
talk about the fight flight or freeze
response right those kind of three
things and
panic attacks i would say you can split
them into those three categories some
people
you wouldn't necessarily know that
they're having a panic attack they just
go completely frozen up i've had a
friend i talked to who said he had a
panic attack on stage while doing a
stand-up gig right and he's at the mic
and he starts having a panic attack now
people
all that people saw was him going
completely silent completely still and
staring out like wall-eyed over this it
looked like stage fright right from his
perspective he's having a panic attack
he can't breathe there are other people
like me that like honestly it looks like
a toddler having a tantrum like i like
i'm like on the floor
i might be screaming might be saying i
can't breathe i'm like sweating i might
be like convulsing you might think i'm
having a heart attack um it was like it
was super embarrassing it was it was
like the most it was like the least
dignified
thing
you could the only way i think it could
have been worse if i was like doing kind
of like honking farts while i was doing
it
so the only thing you could have done
was [ __ ] yourself at the same time that
would have been yeah like you're
emotionally [ __ ] yourself
it's that like complete
like incontinence of like emotion and
terror which would you know
when when we see them in kind of
the panic attack is preserved
amazingly well over like millions of
years of evolution you can get very
similar reactions from
you know like voles and stokes
why does it exist how is it adaptive to
have a panic attack
okay so that's a great that's a
fantastic question and there's loads of
it like people have jumped on this like
going why
and
a
there was a psychiatrist called donald
klein who
in 2003 wrote a paper where his theory
was he sees it as a kind of
um
he called it like a suffocation
false alarm
so he's going back to like we know that
panic attacks can be reliably triggered
by something called the co2 challenge
right where you give someone a mask and
they breathe in a mix of air that's got
25
co2 in it carbon dioxide right that
reliably gives people
like smashes of a panic attack like it's
the grimmiest thing it's quite and i've
spoken to
a psychiatrist who you know
did it himself before he used it in his
experiments but we know that people who
are vulnerable to panic attacks are much
more likely to have
bigger and worse panic attacks when they
do that challenge and it's one breath by
the way like you put this mask on you
take one day no way
i i people who've done it have like said
you can't
i i should say like there's a there's a
famous patient called patient sm who had
her
her amygdal both her amygdalas removed
the mig delay there these parts of the
brain that have often been thought by
kind of like when they talk about them
in magazine articles they call it the
brain's fear center now it's not but
it's definitely implicated in our threat
circuit she had this rare genetic
condition that meant she lost both of
her amygdala were um eaten away by
calcium deposits
she couldn't feel fear she had like a
gun held to her head and someone
threatened to kill her she didn't even
realize that they were threatening her
they've done all these tests on hers
they have held they had her held snakes
they took her to like a fun house and
there was a guy dressed up as like
pinhead out of the hellraiser movies and
apparently she
made him jump because she went up and
grabbed one of the nails coming out of
his mask just to find out what was going
on she's been beaten up she's been
assaulted at no point has she felt fear
she's not all of these were in if not
all of these are in an experiment i'm
going to go no no no no they're super
they're actually the
experimenters all of them that talked
about her
were really sort of protective and
tender about her she wasn't like some
weird like
caged um the problem that you have with
someone that doesn't have any fear is
that they're
pretty bad at looking after themselves
if you're not able to do threat response
or threat detection very well you're
unbelievably vulnerable
yeah she's i mean and that's been a
there's case studies from her life where
you know as straight a really
sketchy guy just like rolled up in his
car and said do you want to get in and
come with me and she was like oh yeah hi
yeah and he took her to a uh abandoned
barn and assaulted her like she's had
that throughout her life trusting people
um but then she does the she does the
mask thing
yeah yeah and then but this is the thing
is like she's just not able to she so
she does this um
she did this uh co2 challenge this 25
and she had the worst panic attack
they'd ever seen
um with that so even somebody who cannot
feel fear in their life
had a panic attack a terrifying one when
she had it now the difference with her
is afterwards they said do you want to
do it again she was like yeah all right
she she wasn't able to learn from the
experience but during it she was
screaming i can't breathe she was
grabbing for the
so so the theory is
um that these chemo receptors in the
brain
are there developed from when we were
kind of like burrowing animals you you
go to sleep in a burrow it collapses
co2 levels will start going up because
you're going to suffocate you want
something that will just flood the body
during sleep
with adrenaline courses i'll get the
heart hammering and go just move
scrabble
thrash around trying to get out that's
that's donald klein's theory that it's
preserved because there was a time when
it was adaptive to wake up suddenly
because you and it kind of still is
right like um we know that children who
um have seizures during the night
um
can
if if if the seizure reaches the
amygdala they are capable of um
just stopping breathing in fact they've
had problems you know this has been one
of the problems with uh covid um they've
been covered patients who stop breathing
have incredibly low oxygen levels
and just aren't aware they call them
happy hypoxics right like the infection
this kind of neuro it might reach the
amygdala and and these chemoreceptors
are somehow
affected in the same way that people
report sort of problems with taste and
smell
and they don't know that they're not
breathing and that little alarm that
says
[ __ ] like you're suffocating you've got
to breathe now and um sort of jolts you
awake doesn't go off and people can just
sit there and pass out um so that's
that's one of the theories another
theory is that like a panic attack is
like
the last resort of the fight flight or
freeze the like most primal response to
being like attacked by a predator like
if everything else has failed if you've
frozen and they still find you if you
try to run away and you still get caught
if you try to fight the last thing is
just to flood the body with adrenaline
and so you thrash you scream you fight
in the hope that like basically
it drops you
that you know or it like
so it's like this last ditch effort um
which is why which is you know one guy i
spoke to john wemmy who's like a
psychiatrist and he does like pulmonary
biology and things like that and he
performs this
co2 test his position was like
he said
when the amygdala is removed what the
amygdala might do is help us decide
which of
the fight flight or freeze options
you've got to choose right when you get
this blood of adrenaline it might help
us decide it
and
when that's removed we might just always
default to the
to the worst thing which is like
panic attacks right so the amygdala is
almost like a kind of spigot that
chooses how much water you want and if
you hack this figure off it's just going
to jet water so that's
one theory of panic attacks
um why why some of the elements of them
might be adaptive
that it's it's a chemo receptor in the
brain
there's very well actually there's
various areas that might have chemo
receptors the amygdala might have them
but also periaqueductal grey kind of
like around the back um that you might
have these oversensitive chemoreceptors
and actually when they've done
ambulatory monitoring of people who have
panic attacks where they monitor their
breathing as they walk around throughout
their daily life they find that a lot of
people who have panic attacks have a
tendency to over breathe right so
they're breathing a lot
they're
washing out carbon dioxide they're
taking in a lot of oxygen and so as they
do that right they're slowly training
this kind of like this canary in the
mine shaft right this these
chemoreceptors to be more and more
acutely aware of the tiniest bit of co2
and so all you need then is a period
where you know people
frequently with panic disorder will wake
up in the night having a panic attack so
there's been no trigger it's not like
they're in a shopping center and they
feel claustrophobic they're in bed and
they wake up thinking they're having a
heart attack right and and so there may
be some dis don't it's it happens
panic disorder correlates with like
sleep apnea and like uh
respiratory
problems people who have them so there
may be some dysregulation of breathing
and then of course what happens if
you're having a panic attack which we
often think is part of it but it's
almost a second stage is then you over
breathe you hyperventilate which
i mean it i don't know like
if you hyperventilate it has all these
crazy effects on
i mean and this is what i didn't realize
i didn't get was like
and it also explains the very
traditional method of stopping someone
having a panic attack right where you
see them on the old movies where they
breathe into a paper bag
and that's not really dealing with panic
attacks so much as the effects of
hyperventilation which are like an over
correction afterwards right someone
breathes and breathes and breathes it
washes out all the co2
and then
with all that
lack of co2 in the bloodstream you get
something called uh cerebral
hypoxia where
um the brain is flooded uh with uh with
oxygen and as a response it uh that you
get the vasoconstriction in the brain so
the capillaries after about a minute of
hyperventilating the capillaries are
about 50 of their previous capacity
right and then and this is all really
complicated it took me ages to get my
head around this because you're like
well the your bloodstream is full of
more oxygen surely your moors go into
your brain well
the body is a homeostatic system and
it's constantly trying to
make sure different areas are getting
what's needed and if your body thinks
it's in fight flight or freeze and
there's
your brain thinks it's getting too much
oxygen it'll go right we don't need this
right we're going to restrict the blood
vessels so the rest of the body
presumably we're being chased or in a
fight right so i'm going to save the
rest of that oxygen to for the
mitochondria in the cells in sort of my
legs so you can run away right so we're
all right here and and that's a mistake
that the brain makes at the same time
you get this thing called a leftward
shift on the
hemoglobin disassociate dissociation
curve which basically means that
hemoglobin the tract the protein
transports of oxygen around the blood
stream cling on to that oxygen more
tightly when you get a carbon dioxide
wash out so it doesn't they don't
deliver those oxygen molecules as
readily so not only does your brain get
50 of the blood flow but all of the
oxygen that's flowing through the
bloodstream is not letting go of
so your brain like within a minute your
brain has been massively starved of
oxygen so you start feeling dizzy you
can't think straight you start getting
that derealization you start thinking
you're going mad
you can't take logical steps
um because your brain is shutting down
and this is why people will regularly
you know like i say they will present
thinking they're having a heart attack
they'll present thinking that they've
gone in that they've lost their mind
um and it's all to do with
respiratory function which is like crazy
which is mad for me right that it's
something so simple as like that
dysregulation and then over breathing
can lead to people gut thinking
i'm going insane and i'm dying and it's
just
a breathing rhythm thing
looking at the techniques that you went
through in an effort to try and discover
what can help anxiety disorders
what did you find out about exercise
so exercise is a really interesting one
i thought exercise was the first thing i
tried right because i was like well this
is a slam dunk i mean i was really
really unfit like incredibly unfit my
job is three meters from my bed
my favorite activities are like
video games and sleeping like i was not
it's no exaggeration to say i was
like i was a dad with a two-year-old
right so like
my sleep patterns were all out of whack
i was
comfort eating because of the anxiety
and because of you know i'd often get my
daughter to bed at a crazy time and then
i'd just like get a takeaway because the
idea of then cooking for myself was
seemed like the least appealing thing
and i thought i fancy you know i
deserved a treat
so but i thought exercise i was like
everyone's always telling me to do
exercise there'll be a shoe-in
and i went and started looking at the
literature i went to see a trainer
called dave thomas who owns a gym in
london who's got like 20 000 hours of
like one-to-one sessions under his belt
to talk to him about like sports science
and stuff like that and i started
digging into the literature and what i
was surprised to find
is the relationship between exercise and
reducing anxiety is by no means clear
there's a really interesting paper by a
psychologist from liverpool university
called peter salmon who looked at a load
of studies on anxiety and exercise and
what he found is that most of the
studies that you will read like in the
paper in magazines that say
you know 15 minutes of hit a day will
reduce exercise will reduce anxiety and
uh whatever
the people they get to do though the
sample that they use for those
are generally and they should be obvious
for us but like
people who sign up to those studies are
not generally people who hate exercise
they need volunteers right and the
people who tend to sign up to exercise
studies tend to be people who quite like
exercise so for a start there's a skewed
sample in that the people who are doing
them are people who
generally don't hate exercise
secondly
the samples that are used and this is
another weird one that surprised me are
often not people who are clinically
anxious
they will
get people who are just you know
everyday people and they will study them
and then they'll give them a survey at
the beginning and a survey at the end
and they'll go do you feel less anxious
now than you did before and often people
do but they weren't clinically anxious
to begin with they just feel more
relaxed does that mean it works with
someone with ptsd or panic disorder
that study doesn't have anything to say
on that necessarily secondly a lot of
studies don't thirdly i should say a lot
of these don't really distinguish
between what type of exercise like
there were a lot you know exercises are
big that's like just saying
you know books is a reading a book good
for you well what kind of book what kind
of exercise is walking the same as
you know sprints or um you know fartlek
or hit
is are we talking like marathon running
are we talking about like swimming um
what what duration is are we talking
relative intensity to someone's fitness
level or absolute intensity uh what how
many days a week for over what period so
all of these questions
are ones that um are not
often well addressed in the current
literature and and of course one of the
things that i got from talking to dave
is like you know if you start an
exercise regime the first thing it's
going to start doing is
at least transiently raise
your cortisol levels your adrenaline
levels you know your
your testosterone levels as well which
is like
more ambiguous when it comes to how that
affects anxiety but your stress hormones
are going to go up initially right
so
and it's going to be unpleasant right
when i started running doing this book i
[ __ ] hated it it was grim i did not
like start running down the street
whistling to myself going i feel so
alive i
oh my god i hated life so much i could
taste blood in my mouth i was limping i
would like i was aching next i couldn't
get up and down the stairs i was so
angry and i was like why am i doing this
i hate doing this
but and there is there is a butt coming
here right like
despite all that so those are all the
caveats right
despite all that
if you then look at the body of
literature
there are some great results like one
thing i'd say like let's imagine that
you did a bunch of exercise right and it
did nothing for your anxiety
but you started a exercise regime well
like we already know you're going to
live longer you're going to have you're
going to you're going to have more
energy during the day you're going to be
your profile risk profile across a range
of diseases is going to drop
dramatically um
so so so the worst case scenario
is that you
live longer you're a healthier better
leaner sexier version of the person you
were yesterday you just still have
anxiety yeah yeah exactly exactly so
like it's not like you know we're asking
someone to put their hand in like a meat
grinder like it's something that's
already good for you i think is sort of
unambiguous across the range of
literature but can it help um
anxiety well there are some suggestions
there are ways it can do like when we
look at athletes and some studies of
people who exercise regularly and do
intense exercise and they've done some
of this with bodybuilders as well
actually in response to a
a threat and in the you know this in the
lab this tends to be something like a uh
they call it like a shock protocol so
they literally wire someone up and give
them
unpredictable electric shocks um that's
how they find out someone's stress
levels and they'll check their cortisol
with a swab
when you look at these people actually
their
fight flight or freeze response their um
hormone cascade
is is generally more pronounced than
people who don't exercise however
it tends to normalize more quickly as
well so they have almost like more of an
adrenaline boost in response to a
stimulus
but then they return to baseline faster
and this is something actually we see a
lot across a lot of anxiety that it's
not so much someone has a bigger it's
not like someone has a bigger startle
reflex although that can be part of it
but that they're worse at responding to
safety cues and returning to baseline
on the other side of it yeah exactly
yeah like like
you know and it was true of me that like
a a can of beans could fall out the
cupboard and now that'd be me gone for
the rest that'd be my nerve shattered
for the morning i'm just like i'm gonna
take to my bed now with a case of the
vapors and fan myself saying what she'll
become of us because like that was it
like my i was just jittery yeah um so
it's gonna normalize that
the other thing
is
and i'm sure you know you'll
be thinking about this as well but like
your blood sugar levels like when in
response to a shock you know your body
is going to release
glucose there's various hormones that um
release you know glucose into the
bloodstream anticipating a threat so
it's going to be available to the
muscles so you can start running and
whatever so it releases these sugar
stores if you don't
immediately use that up
then
your body is is going to release insulin
to reabsorb it so you get these big
crashes so that's why often people will
with anxiety have this horrible up and
down thing where you get the shock and
then you drop into like the equivalent
of a sugar crash afterwards where you
feel sluggish you can't think
and then of course you it's tempting to
like have a sugary sports drink or
something which will sort of briefly
bring you back up and normalize but then
you know you start this kind of like
your days this series of peaks and
troughs
um
exercise can help down regulate some of
the kind of corticoid uh like some of
your um receptors that deal with things
like cortisol to make them slightly less
responsive and they can put you in a
situation where those kind of like
sugar spikes
uh
are less pronounced um they help with
things like in insulin resistance as
well and that's of course you were
shading into diet now but exercise is
part of that as well but yeah what about
that because i've always heard that
there's more
serotonin released in your gut than
there is in your brain and that there's
a good brain connection when it comes to
anxiety and the inflammation is
something that you need to watch out for
because you can eat some gluten and
you'll have an anxiety attack what did
you what's the lessons to be learned
there
yeah so like that's really important and
it's what that serotonin receptors in
that you've got
that idea of like having loads of
serotonin receptors in your gut yeah
like serotonin
hydroxytryptamine um most of it
is you know is doing stuff around in
different things all across your body um
and it's also the reason why you can't
just
take a serotonin pill right because it
doesn't cross the um blood brain barrier
to get into your brain it's not won't be
available in your brain you've got a
blood brain barrier that stops like
nasties getting into your brain
obviously your brain's sort of like very
very that's one of the reasons why you
get kind of like cerebral
vasoconstriction so quickly why it has
these crazy responses is because
it's really really conservative
yeah yeah yeah because it doesn't you
know because getting a virus into your
brain is much much worse than getting
one into your stomach like if it's in
your stomach you can just diarrhea it
out which is one of the functions of
serotonin um in the gut is is what they
call pain it contributes to gut motility
or peristalsis which is why if someone
takes like an ssri a selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor to increase the um
availability of serotonin
one of the side effects is diarrhea um
it's it's also one of the reasons why
like taking
like a real strong serotonin agonist
like psychos psilocybin um can give
someone gut cramps and extreme cases
like diarrhea because it is
that you've got all these serotonin
receptors in the gut yeah that are but
but they do something different
crucially to what what they might do in
the brain um uh mostly they're you know
they're flushing out nasties uh yeah
peristalsis is like the emotional worm
makes and they make your gut do that to
kind of
force stuff through quicker um
so what you eat i'd say like like one of
the key areas for me i spoke to a couple
of people i spoke to a
microbiologist called simon cardin at
the uh
um
and he
deals with well what he deals with like
the i'll take i'll be honest the real
reason i spoke to him like a little bit
is because they do these fecal
microbiota biota transplants right these
fmts where they've been using it to deal
with people who've got c difficile
infections right really serious
life-threatening infections in their
microbiome and what they do is they take
a
cocktail they take basically they takes
they get a fecal transplant from someone
else they someone donates
their
poo
that um who's got a healthy microbiome
they kind of whisk it up and then they
and then they
sort of syringe it into the patients
either up their rear end or that you can
swallow it in something that they call a
crapsule and it'll like restore your
microbiome yeah i know right and there's
all these beautiful stories that are
like my dad's poo saved my life and
stuff that you see in the papers so
that's like well evidence for c
difficile but they started to find these
other things where
um there was so like brave mice where
they took the micro biome from the
quote unquote brave mice these uh these
um
this one strain are known to be more
likely to explore a maze and they'll
jump down from a raised platform quick
quicker and they injected the microbiome
from there
uh from their gut into
well well from a little pouch and so
that mice have called the cecum and they
took that and they injected it into the
timid mice these ones that are a strain
called balb c that come from like a uh
they're traced all the way back to like
a 1913
pet shop dealer in like ohio and they've
been they've just been bread and bread
and bread and they're known to be very
sort of
wimpy mouse equivalent of nervous right
and so they'll inject that microbiome
into those mice and those mice become
braver they become quicker to jump down
from a raised platform so people are
like what the hell's going on here you
can give one microbiome to another type
of mouse that is like genetically that
is like known to be have a hereditary
cowardice
and it changes they don't become as
brave as the other mice but they become
more brave right what's going on here so
they've been looking at it in humans can
we give people can we change people's
gut microbiome um and make them braver
so so the the the disappointing answer
is like at the moment
probably not like we've we've looked at
it for ages and it seems to work with
mice but mice have got like three inches
of gut we've got like three meters
like
there's a reason like we had
it was funny speaking to simon cardin
because he was like almost like pinching
his nose
like the number of times he'd had to
tell journalists
mice and humans are different and it's
like almost surreal to like have that
conversation over and over and over a
mouse is not a per is not a little
person like
they've got all sorts of differences in
their guts they they can't like
mice and rats can't be sick
uh they they don't have a gag reflex so
they've got massive differences in what
they can and can't do
but
in terms of
like your diet um
there's plenty of
like epidemiological studies so big big
big studies where they take huge numbers
of people
that suggest like there's a mild
association with like
a mediterranean diet and lowered risk of
anxiety and uh depression
it's it's not like a huge one it's like
like for one in every 45 people who
switch to a mediterranean diet will
avoid depression or anxiety that would
have otherwise gone but there's like a
smallness but oh you do that over a
population right
and suddenly you are reducing you're
getting hundreds of thousands of fewer
people hitting their mental health
system with anxiety and depression and
hundreds of thousands and that's only
clinical level as well but hundreds of
thousands of people potentially who
aren't having their life like ruined by
this so so you know it gets to big
numbers if you look across a population
um
but
i did speak to you you asked about
inflammation i spoke to a uh an immun
she called herself an immuno
psychiatrist so she called herself that
was her job title she did she's she's at
um the university of southampton dr
rihua who and she told me she looks
exclusively at um
at the links between inflammation
and
depression and also anxiety
and she said that there are you know
what the what we're look we're finding a
bi-directional link between anxiety and
chronic inflammation in the body
now it just so happens that um being
sort of like chronically over
weight
creases inflammation in the body it just
so happens that doing lots of exercise
uh
reduces inflammation in the body so if
there is a bidirectional link between
those two things
we can kind of put the pieces together
and i'm kind of like speculating
slightly although she felt that this was
reasonable um
the the the eating you know a good diet
and
that'd be one you know the mediterranean
style diet you know full of like
um plant-based like polysaccharides lots
of fiber things that are going to like
increase that gut motility and stuff is
going to reduce inflammation
and
reduce your risk pro i think it's i
think it's fair to say reduce your risk
profile of anxiety rather than
immediately cure your anxiety uh she she
also mentioned things that
i on it i thought she was
taking the mickey to be honest when she
told me them because she said oh that so
what's some other things you can do she
said oh like be religious
and i was like that can't be right and
she was like being religious is reduced
with lowered inflammation lowered my
this crt this marker of inflammation
people who are
religious and part of religious
communities have have lower levels of
that i was like so i ended up looking
into the research of that and it is true
doesn't specify what religion so um you
know if you want to kind of
you want to start your own cult
apparently that will reduce your chances
of anxiety as well but
i suppose you know the takeaway from all
of this
is
anxiety is not just one thing it's not
it's a bit more like a headache right
it's a symptom that could have many
causes and it may be that there is a
subgroup
for whom
their chronic anxiety
is arising from chronic inflammation
from a kind of feedback loop from poor
diet lacquer moving around and
sort of lowered hormone profiles across
a range of things there's other things
that
exercise boosts like this neuropeptide
why is this one particular peptide
that's associated with lower anxiety in
people who have it
lower
rates of ptsd in people who have like
high levels of neuropeptide white but
that is produced by doing lots of
exercise so
there is a good chance that there is a
subgroup of anxiety sufferers who may be
you you know they when when we've looked
at the depression
profiles of with uh with inflammation we
can see that there are some people who
respond really well to just taking uh
anti-inflammatories for their for their
depression there is like a subgroup who
seemed that seems to like they started
the crooks of their depression that's
one of the reasons that their depression
manifests
yeah but i would never want to get into
this you you can get sucked into these
sort of arguments where people are going
so are you saying that like anxiety
exists in the brain or are you saying
it's just about
inflammation or are you you know surely
if someone's like having a stressful
life that's going to contribute and
then there'll be other people who say
it's only their environment and you
can't ever say anything about
neuroscience
uh even though like clearly all the
thoughts we're having all the
experiences we're having are
you know in some way instantiated in the
brain like there is a brain is one of
the pieces in this puzzle right
and and sometimes when i get sucked into
those i feel a bit like i'm
watching two people have a brutal
fistfight over whether kermit is a
muppet or a frog you know like it's just
like these things can all
um
be contributors and for me like
inflammation is definitely sort of a
reasonable culprit but it may not be
everybody's sort of primary boogeyman
kind of behind what the
what's giving them anxiety what about
childhood trauma and bullying and stuff
like that how does that contribute
well i spoke to the yeah so i spoke to a
ah i spoke to a brilliant neuroscientist
called um
nim tottenham who has done lots of
studying of like childhood adversity and
particularly how it affects brain
development and how um when people have
had very traumatic childhoods
uh either because of like a single
traumatic incident or because of like
lots of
different things that have happened um
it affects
the suggestions that it it affects brain
development in a way that's not always
immediately apparent at the age of the
trauma but happens later abnormal
development of i've mentioned the
amygdala before but also the
hippocampus which is
associated and implicated in parts of
memory
we're trying to get away from this idea
that one part of the brain is kind of
like one department for doing one thing
but certainly hippocampus is important
in forming memories and
specifically for anxiety it seems to be
to do with um
associating certain environments with
safety or threat which is why there
seems to be a lot of dysregulation in
the hippocampus in um
soldiers with ptsd people coming home
who kind of sensitive to it somehow
yeah you know that kind of like the the
kind of classic thing is like uh car
back firing and they think they're kind
of under gunfire but like that that that
the brain's inability to to
differentiate between a theater of war
and a a
safe zone
um you know the hippocampus is almost
certainly implicated in some level
in that um but nim tottenham and
tottenham looked at how the brain often
those she did this great paper that
showed that like often
this our studies suggest that the brain
starts to change
in adolescence but as a result of things
that happen much much much younger and
we might get
a sort of up regulation of
when you're looking at i guess what they
call like neuroanatomy you might get
much bigger or much smaller
area like the one thing i'd say at the
moment is the literature is really
ambiguous over whether an area like the
amygdala whether i'm having a big
amygdala is
uh worse because you're going to be more
anxious or whether having a smaller one
is worse because you have less
regulation over anxiety it's not
entirely clear what the relationship is
between sort of size
and
function did they say what sort of age
this could begin from are we talking
about before stuff that we could
potentially even remember sort of
toddler age that they could have been
things that have impacted on our brains
from then
absolutely i mean some of some of us i
was looking at one study that was
suggesting that we can't start forming
coherent autobiographical memories that
we're able to retell to people until
about two and a half so
uh you know they could be things that
you don't remember but certainly like
from the moment you're born you you're
you are learning your threat circuits
are active right like babies are not
great at
um
certain types of threat perception but
you
you you come out the womb with sort of
like flinch responses to say like being
dropped or pain or things like that um
babies for a while they've done these
great studies where they get babies to
crawl out over a perspex floor that
suddenly underneath dip like goes is a
cliff like drops away and you know
a crawling age they will just crawl
happily out over the edge um on this
perspex thing they don't know that
they're on a see-through kind of like
ledge um and then there'll be a certain
developmental point where they'll go i'm
not i'm afraid of heights now um so we
know that some
uh fears are uh
are required some are developmental
steps like it's good when a child starts
to get a little bit of stranger fear
there'll be a moment where a child gets
a bit more clingy well they're starting
to differentiate between faces that's
quite good you know obviously like it
can be pathological but it's part it's a
it's a
neuro uh anatomical and neuro
uh
developmental
milestones that's actually pretty great
right like they're learning to go this
face is safe this is a stranger
but yeah from really early on they she
nim tottenham did a great study in mice
um
where they played them music when they
were born like they play a particular
song and then they found mice don't
normally like to nest around any noise
at all like they're naturally timid um
but then
uh if this song was played when they
were adult mice um they would want to go
they'd prefer to go and make their nest
when this music was playing so they
tried it with
um adults they they got butt people in
and they played them songs they did this
very stressful test
um
where it's it's this like notorious test
called the trios where basically you're
made to do
a
a maths test that is rigged
that you're always gonna fail it's gonna
be too hard and the answers come too
quickly there's like a loud horn sounds
every time you get one wrong um
you you can see a bar that supposedly
how other people who've done the test
before did and you're always doing much
worse than that bar right people report
doing this tree as like the most
stressful thing it's more stressful than
like noxious thermal stimuli where their
hand is burnt
more stressful than seeing like graphic
photos of like corpses
the trios is what people find the most
stressful and don't want to go back and
do again
and and she did this test where they
they would be made stressed by that and
then they'd either be played some random
music or one group would play music from
this what they call the critical period
which is like around five and six
and if you played if she found that when
people played the music from five and
six i mean it reliably reduced their
stress levels more than the control
music you mean they went back to the
time when these people would have been
five and six looked at the typical songs
that were playing in the races phil
collins or whatever the [ __ ] yeah yeah
so everyone will have like a critical
period so she think and so she her
theory is this is a critical
developmental period when we are
learning
safety because people who had had a
trauma around that age
um
their
critical developmental period was
shifted earlier to about three or four
so as if the brain just goes
[ __ ] we we'd like we're not going to
have time to fully develop we need to
like get things going right so they
tended to respond better to music that
was what was the responsibility the
threat response was downregulated what
happened yeah so it's the it's lowering
of cortisol levels so they'll do like
cortisol swabs it's also things like
they'll do galvanic skin resistance so
they'll check the sweatiness of skin and
things like heart rate as well they'll
also just get people to
because we can i i got quite like
obsessed with all these kind of like
objective measures of like anxiety but
they'll also just ask people
what is it your subjective except how
stressed are you feeling right now which
is always like a useful thing to do
because sometimes you can get a lot of
studies they've done on neuroscience and
stuff they'll get parts of the brain
that are supposedly associated with
threat um flashing up and they'll go oh
this person must be scared but then when
you ask someone in the scanner are you
feeling scared
they'll go no
and actually some of those studies i
spoke to one neuroscientist
alexander schachtman who was like you
know actually one of the problems we
have
is the tests are kind of boring and
people fall asleep in the scanner so
clearly we can't be studying anxiety if
like someone's like falling asleep
because they're so bored and that you go
you're going these people are scared of
these things so yeah like there was the
response was people were having
they were like moving into that kind of
parasympathetic rest and digest state of
kind of going it's like almost like
those songs are safety cues for them
okay so is it is is the lesson what's
the lesson to take from that when it
comes to childhood trauma and adult
anxiety
well like
there's
there's two and like one of them is like
the obvious ones that like
we've got to like
really protect children and make sure
they grow up in the best environments
possible because these things can have
disproportionate effects on how they
grow up but i would also say
you know as an adult you can if you've
been through difficult things in your
childhood it can be the most
most depressing thing in the world for
someone to go oh yeah i'm afraid you're
screwed and here's like 50 studies
proving it
by all it like we're seeing more and
more like neuroplasticity is still a
thing so
what i would say is
there is clearly an effect from that
critical period of music and you might
find that listening to songs from that
period help you but i'm not convinced
that that having like looked across the
literature that effect is necessarily
bigger than just listening to music that
you love right i'm not sure it might be
an effect but whenever we find an effect
in
uh research we've got to ask compared to
what and there and i'd say probably
those songs do work better than random
songs do they work better than like your
favorite songs i don't know
but in terms of like what we can do
about it the take the takeaway is that
yeah you may have had experiences early
on that have predisposed your brain to
go
not in a nasty way it's not even
pathological it's gone okay the world is
a dangerous place i'm gonna we are gonna
be on the lookout for stuff and we're
gonna
look around and make sure that we spot
this early
so so i you know i'm you know someone
might have
social anxiety right they might like
constantly think does this person hate
me
you know you might be on a train and
there's a couple of people are drinking
and you start getting anxious and you're
one and part of your brain is thinking
is it going to kick off are these people
going to be a couple of drinks down the
line i'm going to start like getting
larry and am i going to be going to get
in a fight well
all of that is actually quite
compassionate and rational of your brain
if you grew up in an environment where
like
don't piss off dad if dad comes home and
he's had a few like just get out the
weight like spot the early warning signs
that someone might be not safe to be
around
like
and try and spot the moments where that
you know the shift in the tone of voice
if you've grown up around that
there's something there's like a little
note of warning in someone's voice and
that is the time you're gonna get you're
going to get hiding if you don't
get out the way
your brain's going to go cool like well
that's cool we're going to apply that
that's an adaptive lesson yeah that's a
useful thing
yeah like if you have a soldier like in
a theater of war who's just prepared to
like walk down
sort of walk through an urban
environment where there are like
installed snipers sort of whistling and
like twilight twiddling an umbrella
around their finger you wouldn't go oh
that's great that's like a healthy human
being who has no anxiety disorder these
things are contextual they're deeply
contextual right but you would think you
would think that person is rightly i
think you would think that person has
lost their mind their behavior would be
maladaptive to be
non-anxious and to not have any threat
perception
in a dangerous environment
is
is is is in some cases fatal
as we've sort of said before when people
you know are unable to tell if someone's
trustworthy or not the question is and i
think the question
that anyone's gotta ask is like is this
how's that working out for you basically
is this still serving me if it's not
there is no indication
that the brain is not
plastic
the brain is changing all the time which
is why i got a lot of neuroscientists
laughing at me when i was going i read a
study that said eight weeks of of of
meditation could change the shape of the
brain and they're like yeah like taking
a [ __ ] take changes the shape of the
brain like if you do that in the same lu
every day like like
every action we do changes the brain
every action we do is making new
connections strengthening connections
wrapping these myelin sheaths around
neurons what this is you know what they
call hebs postulate what fires together
wires together you cannot do a thing in
your life that isn't changing your brain
so i i i would you know i think it's a
really important takeaway is to say like
you
you know of course there are
neurological conditions you can get you
can take a brain injury that affects
your brain but in terms of a childhood
experience
um
meaning that you are destined for all
your life to you can't
get better you can't improve um
i'd say there is
um
the the the the research simply doesn't
support
that at all is the good is the good news
like it is the research doesn't support
the idea that you can't
change the brain i'd say it's almost
impossible not to be changing the brain
with almost every action and decision
you make which is its own kind of
existential crisis you're like what
habits am i laying down you don't get to
not make a habit man you only get to
choose which type of habit you want to
make that's what people need to remember
like every action that you take moves
you toward a tomorrow that is more
likely for you to do that thing again
you know you want to eat the cookie and
not eat the cookie it's not just a case
of eating the cookie is not not eating
the cookie it's also engraining the eat
the cookie
uh module so one of the things talking
about um identity
our sense of self growing up in being an
adult and stuff like that
something that i'm really really
interested in given the fact that you're
a man you're a professional you have an
identity you have people that follow you
online you've got this big course that
loads of people have done about coaching
them to write and stuff father husband
masculine purpose in the modern world
all this sort of thing something that
i'm really interested in is um how you
have dealt with
the
sense of self-referential um
feelings around being someone that has
panic attacks you know did you struggle
with masculinity with your identity with
what you feel your place in the world is
given the fact that you're doing
something that
traditionally is not seen as that
protector provider
stereotype
i mean so yeah yeah absolutely and i
think that
of course like you wanna
part of use like
imagines that you're above all that and
you kind of go well i don't really
you know i don't i i'm confident enough
in my own masculinity to not feel
threatened by that but when
you are
on the floor
like having shoved like a towel in your
mouth
to try and cover the sound of you
screaming
so your baby daughter doesn't hear
because you don't want her to be afraid
in sort of two rooms away on you while
your wife looks after her
and you're cause you're scared of
nothing also also you're just in your
house right there's no threat
um
it's in i think it's impossible for
anyone no matter what their relationship
to masculinity um to feel diminished by
that
we know actually from really some really
interesting studies i read that
people who have more of a sense of
sort of what what we might think of as
sort of traditional
masculine values and i want to be
careful how i say that because that's
that's a bit loaded um but the idea that
men shouldn't get
anxious that men should be sort of
self-sufficient um
consistently have worse and more likely
to get ptsd and have worse symptoms when
when they do
i think if you can't well we know that
the ability to
it's gonna sound so like
it's absolutely simple but the ability
to talk to someone
about what you're feeling
and have it validated and be heard
it's like i think fundamental to getting
over anything to be able to go like
partly because it means you've got to be
able to articulate yourself so it
requires some cell
level of self-insight and if you can't
if you can't
if it shatters your identity to go at
the moment
i'm
really anxious i'm not coping
so you can't let that in
you're going to constantly have an
incongruence between your daily
experience and the person you want to be
and you'll know that you're not living
up to what you want to be right like you
can say it all the time but you know and
so you constantly feel like a failure
right you you continually do
also if you can't
go to a doctor
or you know or just a friend right and
say i'm having the shittiest time i'm
i'm getting like stressed i like getting
keyed up i like i can't sleep at the
moment i'm like keep thinking there's
someone in the back gun gonna break in i
was up at two o'clock like with a
flashlight but all of these things if
you can't speak to someone and they go
yeah like what i was talking about
earlier that sounded like a throwaway
line about religiosity right
reducing inflammation well one of the
reasons that might be
is just people having supportive
communities who they can go to where
it's normalized to go i'm having a [ __ ]
time i've just been bereaved you know
like in a religious community if you
look if you lose someone in your life
they die
it's expected that you'll be able to
talk to them about it
and that is in itself like
has such
a it may even account for many of the
instances of the placebo effect that so
bedevil psychological research in that
just going to someone
in fact when we look across all types of
evidence-based therapy it doesn't matter
what the modality is right it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter what type of
therapy it is they all perform about the
same and
a lot of that i think is just being in a
room with someone
who listens we're a social gregarious
species we are making which is why i
think like so many people found like
locked down and i don't think you could
have done anything worse for people's
mental health than stop people being
able to meet up with each other it's
such a terrifying thing especially and
then people dying out outside right
those two things in combination terrible
for people's mental health and i i i
think that
i think there's loads of great
aspect to masculine values you know it's
one of the things i talked about with
dave thomas about
exercise and stuff um setting and
meeting challenges
is
is one of the things that you know helps
my anxiety the most like pushing myself
not going
i oh i need to sort of back away from
this the more you back away from
challenges i think it's understandable
that we want to people and everyone
around you will say we should you should
rest you should you know give yourself a
break but actually the stuff that's
always helped me has been like
i'm going to train to run a marathon
yeah you know like i've been into it man
that's this is one of the things the
kind of recursive self loop that i see
and i've seen in myself so throughout my
20s i was struggling with low mood
depression
i don't know whether it would have been
clinical i went to a gp when i was 21
and this they gave me a single printout
and sort of ushered me on my way so i'm
hoping that it's the nhs has improved a
little bit since then but um throughout
all of that time
when i was suffering with low mood and
stuff like that
so much of what happens is you become
increasingly less able to lean into
discomfort a difficult thing happens or
there's a challenge that's placed in
front of you and you get to the stage
where getting out of bed
seems like an insurmountable task you
think like i i simply can't go and have
a shower i simply can't
go and
make myself some food or even be
bothered to go and get myself a glass of
water and then you do it and you come
back and you go oh my god like that was
that's me for today that's me done for
the day and then
what you see when you're in a good place
is that that reverses
you see that you're more able you're
more anti-fragile you're going to the
gym and you're putting more weight on
and does this sort of
it is it is a masculine value right you
sort of grit your teeth and get through
this very very difficult thing that
you're doing and it's not out of some
sense of fear it's out of a sense that
you know that you can and you're going
to do more and you're motivated but both
of these spiral either down or up the
same way you know well it it what's so
fascinating about that is that i
actually ended up having that confirmed
the bit where that part clicked for me
was when i was speaking to ai scientists
right there this whole field of
psychology now called computational
psychology where we started making like
self-piloting drones
that would
become
neurotic that would stop leaving the
that would stop leaving the factory
right and we started having ais that
were acting a bit like people with
anxiety disorders right the self-driving
cars really interesting speaking to a
friend who like
works you know as a researcher for
self-driving cars and they had all these
problems with the self-driving cars in
um
milton keynes where they were so
they were they were the you know these
cars are made to not crash into people
right and
the public realized that the cars were
really conservative in how they drive so
they just start walking out in front of
them and it got so self-driving cars
couldn't would like be stopping and
starting and just creeping along because
they get because people
adapt their behavior around them well
what we see with that ais is we started
to
notice that some ais would sort of
would would travel less and less far in
like route finding and then eventually
just wouldn't go anywhere and what it
was is they were
learning about threats taking evasive
action
and then maybe that threat was only
temporary maybe a seagull was flying
through that area at that one time but
because they never try that route again
they stop updating their data on that
because when we do anything and this
comes from like computer from
computational psychology and this kind
of ai science we're actually
surreptitiously doing two things right
we're doing the action we're doing the
behavior we're also collecting data on
the results of that behavior well when
you're depressed if you stop leaving the
house you stop receiving data on what
it's like to leave the house right and
and and and your whole schematic of what
is
what what what threats are in the world
and what the world is even like is
gets more and more
skewed it gets more you get your data
becomes more outdated and you get a data
set from a tinier and tinier cluster of
behaviors well as soon as you start
doing the opposite i wouldn't even say
to people you have to get to the stage
where you believe i can smash this i can
i can get fit
i can go down the gym and i can bench my
my per pass my personal best all you
have to do is be a good scientist and go
should we test this
like should we should we do a test
because like you know you know
depression sitting on your shoulders
like or anxiety or whatever it's going
like okay that is a good hypothesis i
can't do this let's try it out let's see
what happens right
we can do this let let's do four trials
let's let's do this properly right
because if you're so convinced you're
not gonna be scared for me trying this
right
because we you you're going to be proven
rapturously right so let's let's try it
out and then of course what happens is
you go [ __ ]
oh i did that what the what's g so if i
was wrong about that
that one localized misbelief what other
things could i be wrong about and then
the whole
spiral again that's that recursive
spiral that i'm talking about the
problem and the point at which i've been
at staring at the ceiling of a bedroom
for
more days than i can't remember
trying to break
the inertia
between those two worlds
trying to break the inertia of i can't
do this
to
let's try and do this
and that that is the point at which
i got stuck an awful lot and i think a
lot of other people do
and now you know
many years hence and a lot of self work
and stuff like that it's it's
increasingly difficult for me to think
about that and it's increasingly easy
for me to find equanimity when something
bad happens and increasingly easy for me
to lean into discomfort when i need to
as well and you know it might relapse at
some point in the future or whatever but
every single time that even anything
difficult does happen it seems to happen
less and that spiral makes me feel
empathetic for the previous version of
me that i used to be because i know
how far that person was from having that
positive reinforcement from overcoming
something and knowing that we'll be okay
and getting out the other side and it's
fine it's just for now it's not forever
and all of that stuff
that learning process is is very
meaningful
yeah and it's also i mean that feedback
as well they they it it's
it goes back to kind of like the old
kind of like classical conditioning that
pavlov was doing um with with the dogs
where um
he's his um his lab where he was testing
these dogs you know he's ring he was
sounding a buzzer
or having the ticking of a metronome and
showing them like a bowl of meat powder
and they would salivate and he would
measure that that they would certainly
learn to associate the buzzer or the
tinging of the metronome um with food
and they'd salivate just at the noise
right well he had a flood in his lab um
one one night and um all the dogs had to
be rescued and it was very traumatic for
them like the water was coming up to
because it was in a basement area right
and the dogs had like a pretty [ __ ] life
under pavlov anyway but like this was
particularly bad but afterwards
um they found that all the dogs they had
in the lab
were no longer
they couldn't do that classical
conditioning after that they did
something had frozen in them and they
couldn't learn
new associations
and and this has been like in the work
of um
in in the work on learned helplessness
where a dog gets sort of like
one area of the floor will be
electrocuted and another won't and it
will be it'll be shown a light and has
to move from one to the other and
eventually they make the task impossible
for the dog eventually it will just lie
down and let itself be electrocuted and
the only way that you can retrain a dog
that has been through that is the the
the experiment has to like literally go
in and drag the dog onto the safe area
floor to show that its assumptions about
what is and isn't safe once that because
once they make the test
possible to win again the dog won't
bother to learn that it that it can win
it because it's just learned that life
is impossible but the dog's inertia
around its own world view is so high
that it on its own can't overcome it and
and an experimenter has to like come in
literally i mean it's hot don't do that
to dogs like i could have told you that
dog would be depressed if you were
electrocuted repeatedly but nonetheless
the lesson from this is they you know
that you drag the dog onto the safe area
and you do that repeatedly and
eventually it's like
okay my assumptions about the world are
wrong but it is not going to do that
itself and and that's what we can end up
like basically in this kind of metaphor
is is like a it
we just stay on that
electrocuted part of the floor and i saw
this in other
experiments this guy peter loverbond did
one where people would be it get an
electric shock just before a sort of
blue square would be flashed up on the
screen and they'd be told there's a
button right and you can press it
and if you press it
like within a second of the blue square
coming up the electric shock won't
happen and what they found
is that they could the button could be
wired to nothing right and they just
tell people that's what's going on
and they learn to press the button and
they think they're stopping an electric
shock but there was actually never gonna
be one
and then
when they're shown a blue square
people who have that button to press
will get a jolt of anxiety you know all
those kind of like physiological signs
of it even though they've never been
electrocuted by that blue square
and people who weren't given a button to
press who didn't think that there was
any so the safety behavior
who actually then
had the moment of going i'm gonna be
electrocuted
oh
oh no there is no electric shock
unlearn that association and don't find
it scary anymore and this is something
they call safety behaviors like our
ability to people thinking i can't i
have a panic attack on the bus unless i
sit
i have to sit like
one of two seats by the driver and this
is the second bit i wanted to get on
really quick based on what you were
saying about like facing up to stuff
because i spoke to this amazing
researcher from oxford university called
dr andrea reineker who
i heard about someone told me about her
and i thought that can't be true where
she was
solving uh curing people of their
phobias and anxieties like
claustrophobics
by locking them
in a cupboard in a dark cupboard
while giving them this thing called uh
decyclocerium which is like increases
neuroplasticity and saying you won't be
let out like i'm gonna put you in there
and i'm not telling you when i come back
can't call for me don't scream don't do
anything and these are people with like
chronic like really bad
um phobia claustrophobia um and you just
have to trust i'll come back and you
also you can't do any safe behaviors no
taking you know a rescue remedy or a
propranolol you can't like do rosary
beads you can't pray you can't tell
yourself that nice lady be back soon you
just got to sit there and just like
bathe in it how the [ __ ] is this
well it had people's um
they had their had their informed
consent there was a pretty reasonable
dropout rate a lot of people don't want
to go through it right it's rough
um the trip one of the tricks was
actually she came back in 15 minutes
people were had like cleared the whole
day they thought they might be shutting
there all day she came back in 50
minutes her like
cure rate
is one of the highest i've seen out of
any treatment
um we know that like phobias are
probably one of the best
most amenable to treatment out of
anything we can do but these people
would like have their amygdala response
and their phobic response like
normalized i think it was something like
at least two-thirds
that was it like 15 minutes and their
phobia was cured
and their claustrophobia was cured which
is nuts why what's happening there is it
the drug
so decyclocyrene is a controversial drug
to use in this situation i read one
paper that was called right so you will
have already guessed what the problem
with giving something that um increases
neuroplasticity is if you put them in a
very traumatic situation and the paper
was called decyclocerine making um good
exposures better and better exposures
worse right if the person panics in
there and starts doing safety behaviors
um the neuroplasticity um bakes that
trauma in harder which is why um they're
you know they're looking at some other
possibilities because it's a risky thing
to use
um
it's no good sitting down to someone and
saying
the spider isn't going to bite you
like it's
how many times you've been bitten by a
spider
none how how many people do you know
have been killed by spiders in in your
friendship circle in the uk
none right um
it's no good telling someone that it's
not getting to the parts of the brain
that are
making them feel like they're gonna die
and they've got to get out there
you're brain does not believe in hearsay
it doesn't care about that it's got to
experience it and what what going in
that cupboard gives
is like a cast iron experience
you have just gone up against everything
you feared
and it had jack [ __ ] like you turned
round to the axe murderer who's chasing
you in the dream and he stood
and it turned out they were just a
phantom right and there is something i
mean of course like on a like conscious
level
the idea of like facing your fear we can
all kind of like understand how
invigorating that must feel but just on
a on the kind of uh
neurological level and again i'm talking
about i spoke to
several neuroscientists who are like
their names are in i got a copy of the
manual neuroscience out of the library
and i looked up like the la the last
living name in the history section um on
anxiety and then i phoned him i i
emailed him and he was like yeah i'll
speak to you and i i got to speak to
this guy joe
ladue who's like the amazing
uh neuroscientist who deals with anxiety
and like undoubtedly the most famous
in the world
and he said that what you've got to do
is let these parts of the brain he
talked about the amygdala and the
hippocampus just like learn
that the threat
is is not a threat but you can't do that
consciously it's got to happen
non-consciously
it's got to go through it
and go yeah oh
okay stand down everyone like turns out
we were worrying about nothing you can't
talk to that part of the brain
theoretically so having gone through all
of these different strategies tons of
different
techniques for trying to reduce anxiety
what is it that you've come to believe
on the other side of it as someone who
had a lot of first-hand experience
but also has now done a good bit of
research with a thousand papers that
you've read what have you come to
believe about what does and doesn't help
anxiety how's this changed the way that
you deal with it in your daily life
well anxiety makes us crave certainty
right i think anyone who's dealing with
anxiety
wants like i i i don't mind saying i
wanted easy answers right i just wanted
someone to say this is what you need to
do anxiety craves certainty it submits
to authority we want people just to tell
us what to do
and the way out and it sucks is
uncertainty
it's exactly what you were talking about
when you were saying
that moment of doubt where you go what
if my beliefs about the world are wrong
there is something much more terrifying
behind anxiety and i think the key to it
is in people who have been through
childhood traumas
and yet blame themselves somehow
and i spoke to one guy who did like
psychothera psychedelic therapies and
worked with people who've been through
really really grim [ __ ] um
doing psychedelics and i'm doing therapy
while they were under the influence and
um
i said why do people
why would someone think that was their
fault
and the key thing is
if it's not your fault
then it wasn't under your control if it
wasn't under your control there actually
is no sequence of things you can totally
do to stop bad things happening again
that is the
horrible truth about being a human alive
in the world that we are asking anxious
people to embrace when we ask them to
come out of the woods right and i think
that's where we've got to start right
that it's
there's a reason to hold on to the
destructive beliefs of anxiety
and
panic and it is that
if i can just
hate myself enough
i can i can like and set the algorithm
up the fear algorithm i can actually
predict any threat
and i can actually make my life safe you
can't
you you just can't we can do sensible
things i'm not saying you should like
drink a quart of whiskey and go
dance on the motorway but um
you cannot
structure your life to avoid pain
threat like it's just not possible and
that is a bitter pill to swallow
in the midst of anxiety
but
it's also where liberation lies and it
that is
i mean if you told me that at the
beginning i would have been so angry
i've been like you don't understand and
i'd say no i don't understand
so let's talk about it because the other
thing
is all of this stuff about oh this is
how you know the cardiopulmonary system
works this is the hormone cascade is all
for naught unless someone feels
understood this is what uh
uh the anxiety uh therapist of 25 years
this guy he's also an author mike shell
told me he said he used to go in he said
like talking to people about the fight
flight response and telling them all the
literature and just dumping it on them
and he said he realized that you can't
get anywhere
until you feel like you've been
understood until someone has
heard you
and you go
because that was the breakthrough moment
for me and you go that's right
oh you get it that's exactly how it is
and then the other and it's almost like
when you accept that and when you've
been heard
all this other
stuff is like actually all this other
[ __ ] is very relatively easy because we
know like oh people go i know i should
do exercise i know i should eat better i
know i should challenge myself but i
can't and that thing about the
impossible task you were talking about
you can't like put your
people are going we actually we need to
like the world is very stressful and we
need to campaign for sort of a a more
just world well i agree with that
but
at the moment i can't like bring myself
to like have a wash so can you
understand why i'm not in a state to
like upend the current system like
that's not helpful to me well like one
of the things that unlocks that ability
to start doing things that are in your
best interest is in the moment where the
message of anxiety
feels like it's
delivered like the little carrier pigeon
of your anxiety has like delivered that
message to someone and they've heard you
and they've gone that is [ __ ]
and you've explained it to them and you
hear yourself say it as well
and you hear them say it back to you and
you go [ __ ]
that's actually now i say all that out
loud that's pretty bad isn't it i've
been through a lot i'm quite courageous
then like a whole bunch of stuff melts
and then
a whole bunch of
energy that you've been using to be
anxious
you can start like redirecting that
like adrenaline's [ __ ] great you can
use that to like i started doing like
boxing
one-to-one lessons and it like beat the
[ __ ] out of me i went to the guy i was
like can you i just want to learn how to
get punched in the face
and he was like yeah let's do this and
it was great and i'm like it's it is
scary it's not great i don't enjoy
particularly having like someone swing
at me and punch me in the head right
but it's it also is funny
he's funny in a boxing contest
context to do all that stuff and i'm
like oh i've got all this adrenaline and
energy
i can use this to like just rant it on
like a step machine or a or a bike or
doing sprints or like getting the kind
of like battle ropes and you're and it's
knackering you and you're like this
oh like adrenaline feels good so
ultimately i think like none of it
none of it i think can start until
you
have
felt understood and if you can't find
someone else to do that
then
being able to write it down and at least
for you to come
to terms with it you know i think i
think i think everything else comes out
out of that and and that's why some of
this stuff about all the other stuff
that we know we should do but we can't
bring ourselves to do
that falls into place
when that kind of like the core part of
you inside which is just like this kid
that is freaking out
feels like someone's got the message and
then they're like okay stand down alarms
off
now what were you saying about like
eating
some vegetables i can do that now
because i've like delivered my message
tim claire ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out what you do
online where should they go
um you can follow me on twitter at tim
claire
poet or you can just go to my website
tim claire park dot co dot uk and coward
as well your book will be linked in the
show notes below tim i appreciate you
thank you
thank you very much for having me what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace